[Music]
so
okay
today we'll start with a new topic
the topic on strength irrigation system
and
during the discussion when we had
discussed the various methods of
irrigation
we had discussed in brief
what do we mean by what we understand by
the
sprinkle irrigation system
but we have not
gone beyond that we had not looked into
one of the various
types of sprinkler irrigation systems
today we'll start first with
what are the various
types of sprinkler irrigation system
which are there are many many different
uh
modes of
sprinkler irrigation
method which is being
used
all over the world but there are some
some
method which have become more popular so
we'll try to look at those methods first
what are the various types of
sprinkler systems
out of the
various types existing
which are
very common
there are some systems conventional
systems which are
moved with
the manual labor
let me first
put all those which we are going to have
a look at
hand move solid set
side roll
then
center pivot
then you have
that gun
these variations
they have come about
with respect to the
requirements in terms of in some cases
with respect to the requirements of
labor
in some cases you will find that the
labor requirement is very low
so let's have a look at
these
different
types
one by one
the hand move
is the one which we had
discussed during last
the period when we were discussing the
various methods of irrigation where we
had said that
there is a
i mean line
and that
my line will have
different
literals
if we say that this is the main line
now
these littles
are moved
from one position on the lateral to
another position
using the manual labor
you might
again
the
this hand move system you can also
call this as
a portable
portable system
the level of portability
again can vary
in some cases
it can be
it can be completely portable
in terms of you might be
replacing the main line also
and moving it from one plate and one
place to another the next place
but that normally happens when you have
availability of water along a channel
whereas in some other cases it might be
called semi semi portable
right now what we are referring to is a
semi portable system where you are only
removing the laterals
the main line remains fixed
you might move the laterals from one
position to another position
so that the level of portability
can be
varying from situation to situation
there is no
such
rule the extent of portability
can vary
so the other the other extreme can be
the solid set
and this in the case of the solid set
system we might be keeping everything
fixed
the laterals as well as the main lines
they might be remaining fixed
if not
permanently at least for the
duration of the crop
so if you keep the
the little
uh fixed
for the duration of the crop
which in in turn what it will mean it
will mean that you will have to have
those number of lectures which you are
going to use
in any position
so the number of literals requirement
will be very high
in that situation where you are not
willing to remove the
laters you might not be running all the
literals at the same time
you might be running only
one segment
at a time because these things are again
will come to those
details when we'll discuss
that how many liters you can run at a
particular time because all these things
are dependent on
what is the source of water supply
was the quantity of water which is
available and the relevant pressure
so in other words
what is the pump which you are using
on the side of the pump
and that will decide how much how many
liters can be
used in one set or atom at a particular
time
that in turn also is dependent on
what is the pressure requirement in each
each later
because that is what is going to decide
the distribution pattern of the
directed area
or that sprinkler head
so in the case of solid set system
you will
keep the literals permanently fixed
if your labor is very expensive you
might decide to do that but that will be
at the cost of more investment in terms
of having
more number of lectures
then the
the side drawn system
in the case of side growth system
this is
to avoid
the use of labor
if the labor is very expensive
you might want to have a trade-off
between
the situation that in one case in one
extreme you have the solid charge system
where you need number of liters
which have to be bought and fixed
permanently in position or at least for
the the time for the duration of the
crop
the other extreme is that every time you
remove the electrode from
its position on the main line
and then
move the little to the the next position
after
physically dismantling it
which requires
a very regular labor
so to avoid that avoid that situation
and still reduce the number of liters
a system was
a wall where you can have a little
mounted on
some aluminium wheels
and that you can
roll for example you might be having
a little
might have this little and this little
is mounted on
[Applause]
some
reasons
so
through this
mounting
now you can roll the whole thing
and
this itself is a literal that means
there might be
there will be a
nozzle a sprinkler nozzle
mounted on this
now you might
feel that in in some cases if the
sprinkler
is the nozzle is mounted on this
since the whole thing is rolling
it might change the direction of the
sprinkler head so to avoid that
there was a
there's a mechanism by which you can
avoid that
by having a
some mechanism by which you have
a counterweight
which is put so that to keep the
sprinkler head always
and there's that there's a weight which
is put
which is uh quite heavy so
because of that weight the position of
the leaf the the sprinkler head will
always be
in the same position in which you want
it that means the inner position the
vertical position so those things are
taken care of
by having a specialized
those sprinkler heads
which can be mounted on these neutrals
but the advantage of this is that once
you have
done the irrigation or once you have
applied the water by keeping this in one
position you can roll it to the next and
that rolling also can be done
to a
motor
it can be some equipment which can
have some driving force
so that
driving can also be
the equipment can also be
having
that mechanism which can give you the
driving force also
or you can you can move it manually it
depends on what is the size of the whole
the whole
set
that is what we
call the side roll system
which is
quite uh
reasonably useful
in some situations but
is used only in those situations where
you cannot afford to
employ the labor
whereas in our country our conditions in
our country the labor is not that big a
problem so you might not need such a
system
then the central pivot
center pivot system is another system
which requires very
less amount of labor
first of all what the system
was the philosophy of this system
and this particular system
the source of water is
at a central point
and then
from this source
you are having a pivot arm
one pivot arm
which is
quite a
long arm
on which you mount the later
so this pivot can be
i can show you
a figure of
what this pivot
arm can be
is this clear this figure
now this is the pivot term
this pivot arm is having at
different
locations
these sprinkler nozzles are
attached at different locations
all along the pivotal
and this pivot arm if you can notice
here this is mounted on
these wheels
so the whole arm can move in one
direction
it can move
about this pivot point which is the
central point which is the source
this can move in the
in the circular direction
that means if you look at the total
and this since is mounted on
a different job
the mountings are
available
and this
there's a mounted all along on these
tripods
which are
in turn which are mounted on the
wheels
you can give it a
rotation
that means overall
as this moves in this direction
each individual
you will be having
at each location
uh the location of this
sprinkler head either it can be up here
or it can be down there that varies
so in either case
as you have seen in the figure you have
these
sprinkler heads somewhere mounted here
at these locations
in either direction
so when you are operating these
each one is
is wetting area
which has its own
area of influence
so at a at a particular time you are
wetting up
a strip
and
as it moves in this circular direction
at each
individual
time you will find that
ultimately you are wetting
a circular
area
which
which is being wetted by the single
neutral
now this pivot
is it can be very
depends
how big
the pipe you are you have installed
or the pressures under which is
operating but is a real big area
the extent can be in hundreds of meters
so ultimately
you will find that you have
through a
central pivot system
the source was
at the central point
this source can either be in the form of
a valve
or it can be in the form of a buried
main line which has been tapped here
and you will be you will be getting an
area covered which is a circular area
the disadvantage of this
central pivot system
that you are
you are wasting lot of area which is the
cognition
if i
if i have
cover this area with the central pivot
system which is the extent of the
pivot
so ultimately i have covered this area
and normally
whenever you go in for the
the agricultural operations
you won't have the circular radius
covered this is a very big area so it
will be covering many many fields all
along
but still it'll be much more
advantageous if you can
if you can have some
way of covering these corner portions
which
are not being covered in this
in this system so you are wasting
this area is not getting any water
to avoid this
problem
the centripetal pivot system
the movement of the central pivot system
is varied
and is called
a linear move system
with the same as central pivot
but instead of
getting rotated
you are you are moving this pivot
along some channel or some supply source
which is a linear supply source
only then it can
it can be taken care of so and under
those conditions where you can have a
linear movement of this
pivot
you can avoid
getting this
these corner areas
solved you can you can you can you can
solve these areas you can avoid
the situation where where you are having
these
corner areas are not served
by the application of irrigation water
so that is what is
is only the operation
of the
pivot system
or of the
similar
pivot which can be moved in a linear
manner and you can you can take care of
rectangular areas which are more useful
than
the circular areas
then the
big gun
now this system
is having a philosophy that
you are having
a big nozzle
which is operating under much higher
pressures
so what you are doing is that instead of
using many number of
sprinkler heads you are using a sink
single nozzle
which is
having a very distance
very very large distance coverage
and
through the use of that single nozzle
you are
irrigating the areas
the only disadvantage is that the
pressures which are required they are
very very
high pressures
and the distribution is also not
very uniform
in the case of big gun system but in
some situations
the big gun system
can be useful where you're not very much
bothered about the uniformity
the type of crops are not very sensitive
crops
and
you have the prevailing pressures which
are required
now having discussed
the
different types of
irrigation systems
under the sprinkler irrigation system
which are available
we will go on to the other
related aspects of
the system
but most of the times
we will be discussing the the
conventional sprinkler irrigation
systems
where we have
a main line
and the laterals either
flexible or
the
the neutrals which are having
portability all the other fixed neutrals
that
that is only the method of
application
basically it doesn't make any difference
as far as the design is concerned in the
case of design
you have to decide on
what are the pressures what are the
sizes
what are the spacings those things will
come
but we are not going to cover the
designs of
big gun or
of
the central pivot systems
they are
beyond the scope of our coverage here we
are just
in many cases the designs are not much
different or similar because
the the basis behind those designs is
the same
it's not
very much different only thing is that
you will have to take in
into consideration their overlaps
how those overlaps have to be considered
what will be the
difference in the overlap when you have
a pivot system or when you have a linear
system
or the conventional system
so let's go on to the
system components
what are the basic system components
which
have to be
to be taken care of
the first thing is that in all these
systems
this is true for
all the system which we have just
mentioned
that you need
pressurized
water source
that is a must
the extent of this pressures
might be different
from one system to another system
this for example
the the system which we have just
mentioned
for example in the case of
big gun
the prevailing pressures
might vary between
kilopascal
to
1035 kilopascal
and
the impact sprinklers
now these impact sprinklers
are the the conventional systems where
we have
the sprinkler heads
mounted on the
the
littles and the littles are getting
watched from the
main line
and those
systems the pressures
will vary between
these limits
and the
pivot systems
are the system which
comparatively lower pressures
so these are the pressure ranges
now you can see here that the pressure
requirement of the big gun is almost
four times
that of the impact sprinkler
which is conventionally used for
the
areas which are
the reasonably
the reasonable areas which you normally
handle
whereas in the case of pivot system the
areas which you handle
they're very large areas and that is
possible only in the case of
cooperative farming or
where you have
very big farms which are under the same
uh farmers or under
you might have a cooperative so only in
those situations you will find that the
pivot systems are of
much use and you have
for
many many hectares you have the same
crop
but as in our conventional systems
as we know that
in most of our
projects
the availability of the crops is very
high you might have
very small size
fields
which are having the same crop and for
each individual field you will have to
have
the spectral system if you are using one
and the impact impact sprinklers will be
the one which will be quite useful in
other situations
and besides the pressurized water source
you will
need a mini line
a main line is
mill line is the connection between
the
the pressurized source of
water
and
the point of
delivery
this main line might not be required for
some systems
for example when we have discussed the
the
pivot system in that case the main line
is not required directly you are
having the connection between the source
and
the later
the main line is not
available in those systems but in most
of the systems
you will find that the main line is
a very important component of the system
then besides the main line
you have
electric line
the lecture line is the line which
comes after
comes off
of the
the main line
and it delivers the water too
to the individual sprinkler
taking a conventional
system
let's say that this is the source
this is the main line
out of the main line
you
will draw the
the little from the main line
so this is the later
and on the later
these are the positions of
the sprinkler heads
so these are the
sprinkler nozzles
then the other system components
which are related
are that
you would like to know
what is the lateral spacing
and at what spacing you have to provide
these
sprinkle nozzles
on a particular lecture
now if we
call this as sl
and
what is the spacing between
the two lateral positions
on the middle line
so this is
known as main line spacing
and
normally designated by
sm
then besides this
we'll also be interested in
what is the vector diameter
so if you look at the
the area of influence of
this individual
sprinkler nozzle
and this is
this is the wetted area
individual spray pattern
and this area this nozzle
is the paper spray pattern of this
nozzle
that is
designated
by a parameter
which is
known as wetted diameter
and designated by dw
these are the main
quantities or some of the main
items which will be referring to quite
often
these are
the
the design parameters you can see
which will be very important
from
the consideration of our the
objectives of the design
and is very essential to
to know these
parameters
what these parameters
mean
so let us now
look at what are our design objectives
by now we know that
the generic design objectives
which we have which are true for all the
irrigation methods irrespective of which
method you use
and these the design objectives are that
we have to take care of the water
requirements
we have to avoid the
losses
so as to keep those losses as the
minimum ones
they are the same
they are not going to vary much from one
method to another method
but let's have a relook into those
design objectives
the
the required depth of
application
this required depth of application has
to be satisfied
as a prime design objective because you
want the crop to
grow well
without
stresses which it cannot
sustain
those stresses we have to avoid that
those stresses should be
allowed to develop in the crop so for
that purpose we have to ensure that the
required depth of application has to be
provided to the
soil
at the time whenever it is needed
and this we
know that this required depth of
application
is dependent on many factors
is dependent on
the
peak
period evapotranspiration rate
which is a function of the climate so
you have to it will be a function of
what is the peak
you have a transportation date during
that period which is under concentration
and that will decide what is the
required depth of application
will also be dependent on
what is the water holding capacity
of the soil
the
roots on depth
as the these two put together
the extent of the soil profile which is
providing moisture to the crop
and the water holding capacity these two
put together will decide what is the
available washer
and
the management
allowed
depletion
these are the major factors which will
decide
because
when at what exact time you want to
irrigate
that
there is some level of flexibility in
that and that is a function of
decision made either by the farmer or
the management
so that is what we
have discussed earlier that the
management allowed depletion of
the deficit
can also influence
how much is the requirement
at that particular time
then the other design objective is
which is
true for this particular case
and the previous
methods which we have considered so far
this objective was not the one which is
which we are going to discuss right now
this is a very
particular objective which is only
true for the case of sprint irrigation
system
and that is that the
integrate
the integrate of soil
should not exceed
so as to avoid
and in and off
from the irrigation regit field so in
this particular method we don't allow
any enough to generate
which means we will have to
control the irrigation application
to the extent that the
there shouldn't be any
surface runoff
which which might crop up
which means that you'll have to you'll
have to take into consideration
what are the variations and they
integrate
because integrate is something which is
dependent on the soil moisture
conditions
is not
fixed it varies with respect to the soil
object moisture condition
so when we are designing the
the sprinkler irrigation
will have to consider what is the
prevailing
intake rate of the soil
under those conditions
and
control the irrigation application in
such a manner that you don't get any
surface runoff
then we also want
the uniformity of
application
so which is a
objective which is common objective
that was the objective earlier also
and this uniformity of application
will result in
reduction in the leak population
so if your depoculation losses are large
the uniformity will be
the uniformity of
application will be
low
we have to design the system in such a
manner
the uniformity of application can
be as much as possible under the
prevailing
conditions
now
the uniformity of application
at this stage we can just
at least
mention
that in in the case of sprinkler
irrigation system
you are getting a depth of application
by the overlap of
different
application patterns
which are for individual sprinkler heads
so there will be some level of
inaccuracies involved
or some level of
non-uniformities which will be involved
because of these overlaps
and that will be
dependent on many other factors for
example the wind conditions
which is going to be a major factor
in deciding
how well you can
have the overlap
how effective overlap can be
obtained
under those
prevailing wind conditions
will be a function of the level of wind
conditions
if the wind conditions are very
excessive the wind speeds are very
excessive you might find that the
overlaps
might be very difficult to
obtain
the uniformity throughout the area we'll
discuss those things in detail i thought
i'll just
mention make a mention at this stage
that this is one of the the condition
which will
decide
how much
will be the uniformity which can be
achieved
in this system another design objective
which is
very often
can be a deciding factor
is the trade-off between
the
achieving the physical
conditions
the physical requirements of the crop
and
in achieving those requirements how much
you have to
incur
how much expensive
the system can be or how much expense
you have to incur
so
the
economy of the overall
system
is going to be a very major factor in
this
tradeoff between
physical
plus
biological requirements
and
on the other hand
the
economic cause
of
equipment plus labor
these two
factors are going to be the deciding
ones
in some cases if you change the design
you might
that your initial cost
goes up very much
you might have to invest a lot of money
in providing all those
equipment
example if you go in for the
permanent set system
is going to be the
fixed system
you will require
a lot of pipes
which will which will add to your
initial
investment
whereas if you go in for a flexible
system your label costs
will be quite excessive
similarly the costs like maintenance
cause
the recurring cost
all those things you'll have to see
and compare them
under different options
but at the same time you'll also have to
look at
how well you are
by choosing a particular system how well
you are in a position to cater to the
requirements which is the basic need of
the education system
so
this trade-off is a very important
aspect and
as a very subjective thing
this trade-off will vary from place to
place
and those conditions are in those
countries where the equipment is very
expensive
people might go in for
the labor is cheap you might choose a
different option than in those places
where is the other way around
so uh is this totally
is a very subjective
objective
the design objective
and vary from place to place is very
essential to understand that but it can
be a deciding factor
in many situations
then
let's go on to the
some other aspects which are uh
which we must understand before we go on
to the next
level of
looking into the designs of these
systems as the uniformity of
applications
we just mentioned
in our objectives that we need to
get uniformity of application
that uniformity of application is
dependent on
two
basic factors
one is the
the pressure
the prevailing pressure
and the others
the
wind conditions
how the pressure influences the
uniformity of application
let's take
three different cases
when we operate the sprinkler
nozzle
under three different
pressures
and this is my
location of the
sprinkler nozzle
let's say that this is the
distance this is the zero level
10 20
30 meters
so this is the central point where the
the sprinkler is fixed
now if the pressure is
too low
we won't get the order of magnitude we
are just saying relatively
because that will be the the
this variation
of the distribution of water
will vary with respect to the size of
the nozzle and the pressure
so we are just
trying to look at how
relatively
the special distribution will change the
pressure variation will change the
distribution fraction
when the pressure is low
you might find that
you might get a
distribution
of water which is
something of this
this nature
because in this case what is happening
is that
since the pressure is low
when the
the jet comes out of the
nozzle
is not broken up
into smaller particles
is not fully broken up is not broken up
to the extent that it can
get distributed over this area of
influence
in a uniform manner
it might be
having some still some streams which are
going as a stream of water there is some
breakage of jet
but not is only partial breakage
so if that
happens you will find that
this type of variation will be absorbed
on the other hand
if the pressure is
too high
you might get a variation which is
something of
this nature
and
the pressure the
variation of
the distribution
might be something like
a triangular variation
if the
pressure is satisfactory
now why we are saying that this is
this variation this distribution is more
acceptable
because ultimately
we have to get the
overall distribution
by overlapping these
individual
distribution patterns
and is very difficult to
get a uniform distribution the overall
uniform distribution by
having either of these two distribution
patterns
that's the reason otherwise there's no
other reason this is the only reason
that why we want
a distribution pattern of this type
why we are calling this pressure to be
satisfactory because
by having this type of precedent
distribution is much easier
to have a better
uniformity
of application
okay
any question
so stop here
[Music]
you